if aliens came to earth and were
observing humans
would they notice our
distributed cognition first
or our individual cognition first what
is the most notable thing about us
humans
is it our ability to individually do
well in iq tests or whatever yeah uh or
puzzle solve or is it this thing we're
doing together
i think most of our problem solving is
done in distributed cognition
like look around
you didn't make this equipment you
didn't build this place you didn't
invent this language that we're both
sharing et cetera et cetera
and now there's there's more specific
and precise experimental evidence coming
out
let's take a standard task that people
reasoning task i wanted to do the
details it's called the waste and
selection task
and you give it to people
highly educated psychology students
premier universities across the world
you've been we've been doing it since
the 60s it's replicates and replicates
and only 10 of the people get it right
you put them in a group of four
and you allow them to talk to each other
the success rate goes to 80 percent
that's just one example of a now a
phenomenon that's coming to the fore
by the way do you know a similar
experiment has been done on a group of
engineering students for psychology
students is there a major group
differences in iq between those two just
kidding um that's uh
let's move on uh all right so there is a
lot of evidence that there's power to
this distributed cognition now what
about this mechanism this fascinating
mechanism of the ants interacting with
each other the dialogue
i use the word discourse or dialogue for
just people having a conversation
but and this is deeply inspired by
um
socrates and plato especially the
platonic dialogues
and i'm sure we've all had this and so
give me a moment because i want to build
onto something here we've participated
in conversations
that took on a life of their own
and took us both in directions we did
not anticipate
afforded us insights that we could not
have had on our own and we don't have to
have come to an agreement but we were
both moved and we're both drawn into
insight and we feel like wow that was
one of the best moments of my life
because we feel
how that
introduced us to a capacity for tapping
into a flow state within distributed
cognition
that puts us into a deeper relationship
with ourselves
with another person and potentially with
the world
that's what i mean by deal logos
and so for me
i think the logos is
more
important
huh boy
i could just
i'm sorry i can hear jordan and jonathan
in my head right now but i think it's
more i hear them all the time
i just wish they would shut up in my
head
sometimes
uh so what are they saying to you in
your head what they're saying is well
see that's what the most recent
conversation was about i was trying to
say
that i don't think mythos
is i think mythos is really important
i think these kinds of narratives are
really important but i think this
ability to connect together
in distributed cognition collective
intelligence
and
cultivate
a shared flow state within that
collective intelligence so it starts to
ramp up perhaps towards collective
wisdom i think that's more important
because i think that's the basin within
which the myths and the rituals are
ultimately created and when they
function
like a myth is like a public dream
it depends on distributed cognition and
it depends on people enacting it and
getting into mutual flow states
so the the highest form of dialogue
of conversation is this flow state and
that it forms the
foundation for myth building i think so
i think so so that communitas that's
victor turner's phrase and he
specifically linked it to flow and i
study flow scientifically that you know
that within distributed cognition as as
as as the home as the generator of
mythos and ritual and those are bound
together as well i think that's
fundamentally correct you know what's
the cool thing here because i'm a huge
fan of podcasts uh and audio books but
podcasts in particular is relevant here
is there's a third person in this room
listening now
and
and they're
also in the flow state yes yes
like i'm i'm close friends with a lot of
podcasts they don't know i exist i just
listen to them and because i've been in
so many flow states with them and i was
like yes yes yes this is good
but they don't they don't know i exist
but they are in conversation with me
ultimately and think think likes of what
what that's doing you've got like you've
got dialogues and then you've got this
meta dialogue like you're describing and
think about how things like podcasts and
youtube they break down old boundaries
between the private and the public
between writing and oral speech so we
have the dynamics of living oral speech
but it has the permanency of writing
like we're we're we're in the midst of
creating a vehicle right and and a
medium for distributed cognition that
breaks down
a lot of the categories by which we
organized our cognition i mean because
of the tools of youtube and so on just
the
the network the the graph of how quickly
the distributed cognition can spread is
really powerful and just a huge amount
of people have listened to your lectures
yeah i've listened to your lectures but
i've experienced them as at least in
your style
there's something about your style it
felt like a conversation yeah like it
felt like at any point moment i could
interrupt you and say something
oh and i was just listening thank you
thank you for saying that because i
aspire
to being genuinely
as socratic as i can when i'm doing this
yeah there was that sense actually as
i'm saying it now why was that it didn't
feel like sometimes lectures are kind of
uh you you know you came you come down
with the commandments and you just you
have
but there was a sense like i mean i
think it was the excitement that you
have like you have to understand and
also the fact that you were kind of
i think
thinking off the top of your head
sometimes yes there was a
you were interrupting yourself with
thoughts yes you're playing with
thoughts like you're you're reasoning
through things often like i've you had
well you referenced a lot of books so
surely you were extremely well prepared
and you're referencing a lot of ideas
but then you're also struggling in the
way to present those ideas yes there was
and so the jazz like the
jazz and getting into the flow state and
and trying to
share in a participatory and
perspectival fashion the learning with
the people rather than just pronouncing
at them
you